the vaccine push
has really pushed guys to the brink
and it's like this is a bridge too far
and i've bitten my i i bit my tongue and
held my
thoughts on the political stuff and and
everybody's sitting around acting like
america is the most evil place on the
planet that
they struggled with that but they were
able to ho but now it's about injecting
things into my body when you're talking
about the the young some of the youngest
healthiest most in shape people on the
planet their the the death rate the
damage rate for covert for these people
is virtually non-existent
and so i have seen a growing discontent
there and i think it's helping them
realize like oh
so when we accepted
the kneeling
and the national anthem
we never thought it would get here and
now they're starting yeah that's why you
got to draw a line in the sand on all
this stuff because eventually it is
going to come for you
which sport you know we're talking about
the nba now but you mentioned the nfl
those seem to be the two that are having
this meltdown and by the way when you
mention the seven percent increase i'm
guessing that the year before ratings
were considerably more down from the
year before so it's it's sort of like a
like a not as great number right when
they're talking about that but which
sport do you think has suffered the most
from all this it seems like the nba to
me but i'm a little out of the loop
it's hard for me to say
who has suffered the most
i i would probably argue
i'm not going to say sports nfl players
have suffered the most
they
allowed ownership
to
jam a collective bargaining agreement
and a salary cap down their throat
before
uh the tv deals were struck
and and it was all under the excuse
we'll cover it and you know we're not
going to generate as much money and so
even with all the money the nfl players
are making and they're making a ton
compared to what what they used to and
you know guys like patrick holmes and
dak prescott are making more than 40
million dollars a year
they're not making what they could and
should be making
if
the covert charade if they hadn't
damaged their business with the
george floyd colin kaepernick
let's piss off our traditional fan base
and so i'm not sure if i'm quite
answering your question but i would say
over the course of these
five or six years
the kaepernick charade
george floyd charade and now covet i
don't think any sport has been more
damaged than football players
and and and football and again i i i
i say that saying the full impact of
what they've done over the last five
years
is going to play out
over the next 10 years everybody right
now is you know early on football i love
it and i'm going to these games and it's
screw fouchy we're partying and acting
like it's 1999.
a bit when that dissipates and when
people are sitting there because i'm
tell week one of the nfl i'm sitting
around watching football it's what i was
built in this life to do watch football
talk about it used to play a little bit
of it in college
but i'm just not as passionate
and eventually that that lack of passion
once the thrill is gone the love is gone
and people understand like man i'm just
really putting money in some ungrateful
idiot's pockets
uh
you know what i'm tired of doing this
and i'm gonna spend time with my wife
and kids or family i'm gonna go hunting
i'm gonna go fishing there's other
things to do
then watch people that you don't respect
play a game that's been softened up and
dramatically changed the the point i was
arguing on wednesday on my show is like
the nfl has made a bunch of decisions
over the past 10 years under roger
goodell
to satisfy its critics
they've changed the rules because of
head trauma and the new york times beat
them up over cte
uh you know they allowed kneeling
because of colin kaepernick because of
george floyd they passed plastered
all these marxist social justice slogans
all over everything it it's
they're you know and people call me a
sexist pig but they're they're
decorating their
officiating crews with women
they're coaching staffs with women their
executive offices with women and they're
doing all this to stay a step ahead of
the me too feminist movement
and they're just piling on people and
i'm not saying look there i know some
women who love football i know but
they're just pacifying people
whose hearts really aren't in the game
and they're pacifying the people that
don't really love the game
and they're doing nothing
to satisfy me
their
a1
ride or die
football fan what about me they just
take me for granted and eventually guys
like i'm going to join guys like you to
just say you know what i got better
things to do
so when they said the nfl is gay did you
have any clue as to what they meant by
that i mean they literally it was a
commercial the nfl is gay
i know a little bit about that but
i couldn't put it all together
uh i
dave and and and
i want to be respectful because i but i
i just
i say there's an alphabet mafia blm
lgbt i'm with you
that's the mafia now and
it's it's
everything is being done to say
don't attack me black lives matter
lgbt movement don't attack me and so
they you know the nfl is gonna say i'm
gay i'm marxist i'm gonna say the cops
are out randomly killing black people
i i'm gonna say whatever i think is
necessary to keep you off my back
and
uh
listen i
grew up
as an idiot in a football locker room as
an athlete
i can't say i was as dumb as all the
guys i played sports with but i i'm
certainly remember i'm 54 dave i
certainly remember in my era
guys that were less
masculine than the standard were
mistreated
and i am
really glad and thankful that that has
changed and we're we're going a
different direction and everybody that
kind of bullying should not have been
tolerated then and i'm glad we're not
tolerating it now
but
i still think there needs to be i can't
be made to feel bad
of course because maybe i'm a little i
got a little bit more masculinity than
the normal person
and i'm just football is a masculine
game
it's not about your sexuality for
someone like myself dave
i think we've all gone overboard with
our sexual identities
and we're all wearing them on our sleeve
and it's like the first thing we tell
people
i'm heterosexual and boy do i like
vaginas
and yeah
the key to saving this country because i
do believe like the country's at stake i
do
we have to go back to hey
i'm a christian or i'm an american
let that be your initial identity rather
than your sexual identity because i just
don't think what arouses us sexually
is all that important and i'll say this
as a christian
and who was someone who i think as a kid
and as a young person could be
accurately described as homophobic
and and i i regret that and i regret
that as a christian because
regardless of what i think about
homosexuality
it's no different for me as a christian
than my promiscuity outside of marriage
and so
it was wrong to try us as christians
that have these certain beliefs to try
to say our sin isn't as bad as their sin
and and
it's how we have cr we have created and
i blame us as christians for not being
more tolerant and more understanding
we've created this backlash
and
uh the alphabet mafia
and and now i've seen people rather than
admitting their flaws
and then doing the right thing i see the
nfl and other sports leagues
bending over backwards and doing things
that they really don't believe
to pacify
social media the twitter mob
and
ever all the other people that are
allegedly on the right side of history
yeah well jason let me say this as an
american you get no judgment uh from me
on any of your past judgments let me
just be very very clear about that was
it not joe namath who said i was a gay
marxist was it not him wasn't he a big
gay mark sister am i confusing him with
somebody else
joe
joe neighbor did not was it it wasn't
joe namath what was it
let me ask you
i'm guessing you you talked to to
players in these leagues uh probably
probably on the dl uh but i i have a
friend or two that's in the nba and i
know that that guys are not happy about
this they are not happy about the
politics in the sports they're not happy
about the the influence of china there's
a couple people that that privately will
talk about this not much not many that
will talk about it publicly and
certainly most of the coaches and steve
kerr and popovich and lebron obviously
just just love it on china all day long
but do you sense players are angry about
all of this stuff too
i think where players have gotten more
aggressive
and it's still not aggressive enough
the vaccine push
has really pushed guys to the brink
and it's like this is a bridge too far
and i've bitten my i i bit my tongue and
held my
thoughts on the political stuff and and
everybody sitting around acting like
america is the most evil place on the
planet that
they struggled with that but they were
able to hold but now it's about
injecting things into my body
when you're talking about the the young
some of the youngest healthiest most in
shape people on the planet they're you
the the death rate the damage rate for
covet for these people is virtually
non-existent
and so i have seen a growing discontent
there and i think it's helping them
realize like oh
so when we accepted
the kneeling
and the national anthem
we never thought it would get here
and now they're starting yeah that's why
you got to draw a line in the sand on
all this stuff because eventually it is
going to come for you
and and so i i do think there's a lot of
players that know like
man
you know what i'm able to do for my
family because of football and
basketball and america's passion for
sports
why are we sitting up here like we
are the people the most irate and think
america is evil yeah i i i've heard from
enough players particularly during this
vaccine thing that
it's going too far
and they know how hypocritical it is
they know that it's driven by
the players who are addicted to social
media
and and you know would would rather die
than do anything that didn't get a
thousand likes and 500 retweets
and and
i i
but what most people are doing and this
is
their fault the players are following
the lead
of roger goodell
uh the executives in the nfl the owner
everybody's just trying to do
what's best for them in the moment if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell